[Music]
microbes are everywhere on your phone in
your water bottle on your hands before
you wash them on your hands after you
wash them and literally everywhere else
on top of you - microbes are omnipresent
at any moment and there is nothing we
can do about it so millions of years ago
we made a pact we give them shelter and
food and in turn they work for us but
the more we learn about this partnership
the more it looks like a cold war inside
our mother's womb humans start out
sterile when we are born and traveling
through the birth canal billions of our
mother's bacteria cover every single
part of our bodies this is an essential
part of human health children born via
c-section have a higher rate of asthma
immune diseases and even leukemia so our
bodies do not only accept the invasion
of microorganisms they welcome it over
millions of years we co-evolved to make
the best of our relationship mother's
milk for example contains special sugars
that are meant to feed and support
certain groups of microbes work as a
decoy for others and help to modulate
the immune system it takes up to two
years until a healthy microbe community
has formed every human has their own
unique microbiome made up of bacteria
viruses fungi and other organisms we
have three categories of guests on and
in our bodies one quiet passengers that
do their own thing and are politely
ignored by being there they take up
space and keep more aggressive intruders
in check
two guests that harm us but with whom
we've learned to live for example
bacteria that literally create acid that
melts our teeth if we don't brush enough
they want to take up as much space as
they can and we don't want them to but
we can't get rid of them entirely three
friendly fellows that our bodies want to
have around most of them are a community
of 380,000 billion bacteria from up to
5,000 different species that live in our
gut these gut microorganisms help us
digest food and pull additional calories
from things we can't digest ourselves
unfortunately our gut is also the
perfect point of attack for intruders
so it's guarded by an aggressive army
our immune system to survive here how
microbiome co-evolved with us to be able
to communicate with our body the most
important part of that is to ask the
immune system to not kill them but they
also have a real motivation to keep our
gut healthy so some of them produce a
messenger substances that help to
educate the immune system and others
stimulate the gut cells to regenerate
faster but over the last few years
evidence has emerged that the influence
of our gut microbiome goes much much
further it might even talk directly to
our brain we've observed a few curious
things 90% of our body's serotonin an
important messenger substance for nerve
cells is produced in the gut some
scientists think the microbiome does
this to communicate with the vagus nerve
the information highway of our nervous
system other examples are bacteria that
stimulate immune cells in the gut so
they send a kind of alarm signal to the
brain here it activates immune cells
that help the brain recover from
injuries since the brain decides well we
eat the microbiome is interested in a
healthy brain
a new field of science is opening up
here and we're just on the verge of
understanding how these complex systems
inside our bodies interact but we are
starting to see how much our microbiome
actually influences us and our behavior
take depression for example healthy rats
fed microbes from the guts of depressed
people began showing anxiety-like
behavior and symptoms that look like
depression and in early 2017 a study
linked the microbiome to intelligence by
connecting a certain set up of bacteria
in newborns with better motor and
language skills but it might also
influence our daily lives tests with
fruit flies showed that their microbiome
influenced what kinds of food they
craved this could mean your microbes are
able to tell your brain which food it
should get them although this is not a
one-way street the seed for our
microbiome comes from our mother but how
it develops and changes is determined by
what we eat the organisms in our gut
feed on different things
some like fibers and leafy greens others
go for sugars and starches and some love
greasy fries and butter our gut is like
a garden in which we constantly decide
what will grow and blossom if we eat
healthily we breed bacteria that like
healthy food if we eat a lot of fast
food then we breed fast food loving
bacteria life is hard so we can get
trapped in a vicious circle
you have a stressful time and eat lots
of burgers and fries and pizza this is
awesome for fast food bacteria they
multiply and multiply and take up space
from vegetable living bacteria but even
worse they send signals to the brain to
continue what it's doing this makes you
want more fast food which breeds more
fast food bacteria which makes you crave
fast food and so on this kind of
self-reinforcing cycle could play a huge
role in obesity but it's important to
stress that you can fight this process
and reverse it by eating healthily
and breeding malls good bacteria beyond
weight gain our microbiome has also been
linked to other serious diseases like
autism schizophrenia and cancer one of
the earliest symptoms of Parkinson's is
actually gut problems if your body is
overrun with bacteria that harm you
there is often only one solution you
bring in an army of good guys that's
very easy you just transplant some
healthy poop you do that by literally
transferring poop from a healthy person
into your gut this method is already
used to cure diarrhea that's caused when
c difficile bacteria take over a gut
microbiome but we just don't know enough
about the complex interplay at work here
yet for example a transplant from an
overweight donor cured a woman's
diarrhea but contributed to her obesity
down the line this caused some ways and
another study tried to reverse the
effect poop transplants from slim people
to obese ones gave them a more diverse
microbiome and made them less sensitive
to insulin both things that also happen
when people lose weight we need to do a
lot more science to really understand
how our microbes make us healthy or sick
but whether we like it or not we need
our microbiome and it needs us
we'll never have our bodies to ourselves
but we have gained a powerful ally if we
can just keep the peace
[Music]
you